[Musique]
yavne ou sur les plots et dans votre
platine
vous pouvez déverrouiller des défis et
acheter la base d'un combat pour
recruter cette équipe de naufragés
insubmersible ce petit moussaillon
s'appelle quitte
quand ils grandissent si vite j'ai
invité aquaman il a dit oui alors je lui
ai demandé de mettre un tee shirt il a
dit non et pillages il y une aventis de
génie aux créations prodigieuse explorer
la fatigue pour rencontrer toute
l'équipe
découvrez aussi le parapluie perso
inclus dans le poste de combat et à
redécorer vous même mme à la fin de la
saison il sera totalement unique
tout au long de votre aventure de
nouveaux endroits de nouveaux moyens de
se déplacer et débats de surprises vous
attendent
soyez bret alors acheté le bas de combat
pour recruter votre équipe d'ouvragé
personnalisez votre part a pu récupérer
1500 des bugs et plus encore qu'est-ce
que plus à tomber et jetez vous à l'eau